and the oscar goes too
it was such a blur and we were like what
are we doing here you never believe in
your lifetime that you would ever be
nominated for let's much less win an
oscar so when they actually say your
name you go into a little bit of a shock
trauma place kristen anderson lopez and
robert lopez for let it go frozen
[Music]
i hadn't won anything so like it's weird
to have one of the first things you
really win in public like that be an
oscar
um
so that was really strange
it certainly felt great to walk down the
aisle i felt like getting married again
because this is my wife
um and it reminded me of that same
moment you're just like this is really
happening our work just won the oscar
it's amazing i think that's why i turned
to you and kissed you i just have to
have this moment of connection with him
the part i don't remember is
getting up to the stage jamie foxx oh i
asked jamie foxx to hold my purse
because i didn't know how i was going to
hold my speech and hold the oscar so i
was like would you hold this and then i
was like
like ask jamie foxx
we have so many people to thank luckily
everybody's name rhymes idina menzel
kristen bell jennifer lee peter delvey
you want to know why it rhymed when we
went to go write it we realized that i
was like thank you to kristen bell and
idina menzel and i was like oh i got to
keep going with this chris montan arimis
metzger bestermann the anderson and the
lopez plan i definitely remember being
like that i have a speech and it rhymes
and i really want to get to the end and
i want to make sure we don't get played
off i wanted to make sure i had a second
to say the thing at the end one of the
whole things that had driven all of the
writing of frozen and especially the
writing of let it go
was the feeling of
trying to live up to expectations and
last but not least our girls katie and
annie this song is inspired by our love
for you and the hope that you never let
fear or shame keep you from celebrating
the unique people that you are
thank you we love you we love you thank
you
[Music]